اجراءات امنيه مشدده فرضتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قبيل انطلاق صلاه الجمعه هنا
في المسجد الاقصى اقامت عددا من الحواجز
كما
ترون حول البوابات كما هو الحال هنا في
باب الاسباط المؤديه طبعا الى المسجد
الاقصى تقوم بمنع الفلسطينيين من الوصول
لتاديه الصلاه وهي التي لم تحدد مسبقا من
هي الفئه العمريه التي كانها الدخول من
اجل تاديه الصلاه من عدمه وايضا قامت
باقامه حواجز في كل البوابات بوابات
البلده القديمه هذه الاجراءات التعسفيه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال تاتي يوما واحدا فقط
بعد ان اقام المستوطنون المتشددون مسيره
داخل البلده القديمه وذلك بالتزامن مع
اقامه الفلسطينيين لشعائر ليله الاسراء
والمعراج ورددوا
شعائره تلميه وايضا كانت هناك مناوشات بين
المستوطنين المتشددين وايضا الشبان
الفلسطينيين داخل البلده القديمه كل هذا
وسط ازدياد المخاوف من اقتراب شهر رمضان
المبارك ومن ان تؤدي مثل هذه الاجراءات
التعسفيه الى ازدياد حاله التوتر داخل
المسجد الاقصى وفي البلده القديمه وايضا
في القدس المحتل
امين درغامي الجزيره من القدس المحتله